حسين يزدان بانا زعيم حزب تحرير كردستان
وقائد الجناح العسكري للحزب شكرا جزيلا لك
على قبول الحديث معنا مرحبا بكم توصفون
كحزب كردي انفصالي لماذا الانفصال عن
ايران ياسيني ودولتي
رقيبه سمحت القوانين الدوليه لكل امه وشعب
بتقرير مصيره يتضمن ذلك ايضا انشاء دوله
واعلان الاستقلال لدينا خبره 100 عام مع
الدوله الفارسيه طوال ذلك الوقت لم نرى اي
فرصه للعيش في ظل قواعد ديمقراطيه مع
طهران اعلان الاستقلال حقنا لاننا امه
وشعب يحق لنا المطالبه بالاستقلال لذلك
نعتقد انه فقط من خلال الاستقلال يمكننا
تحقيق التنميه في بلدنا هذا حقنا ونحن
نناضل من اجل ذلك امثله في كندا واسكتلندا
في بريطانيا امثله جيده
مع الدوله المركزيه من اجل اجراء استفتاء
في كردستان اذا سمحت الحكومه بذلك فهي
طريقه ديمقراطيه ونحن نرحب بهذه الخطوه
ولكن اذا لم يكن ذلك مسموحا به فسنستخدم
اي وسيله اخرى لضمان هذا الحق نحن على ثقه
من اننا سنحقق هذا الهدفعي
كيف ستحققون هذا الانفصال هل يعني هذا
مواجهه امنيه مع النظام الايراني ايما
حسدكين
نريد تحقيق الاستقلال من خلال الاتفاقيات
الدوليه هذا ما نرغب فيه ومع ذلك فان
الانظمه في طهران منذ الملك رضا بهلوي حتى
خامنئي لم تتخذ خطوه في هذا الصدد نحن على
ثقه من ان حكام الفرس في المستقبل ايضا لن
يعترفوا بالاتفاقيات الدوليه لمنح حقوقنا
لذلك نحن نناضل ونقاتل من اجل هذا الحق في
شوارع كردستان من خلال الاجراءات المدنيه
نحاول تامين حقوقنا دون اراقه الدماء بحيث
يتم تنفيذ الفصل مثل تشيكوزلوفاكيا
هل الصالحه
في غضون ذلك سندافع عن انفسنا ضد كل
الهجمات كما فعلنا في المئه عام الماضيه
لدينا الحق في الدفاع الشرعي
هل ستشنون هجمات على الداخل الايراني
السلطات الايرانيه تتهمكم بذلك
في الواقع لم نشن اي هجوم على النظام
الايراني من داخل كردستان العراق لن نشن
هجمات على الجمهوريه الاسلاميه من كردستان
العراق ناخذ بعين الاعتبار سلامه وامن
كردستان العراق وحدودها ما تم القيام به
سابقا كان من خلال وحداتنا الحزبيه داخل
كردستان الشرقيه وحداتنا العسكريه واجهت
قوات الدوله كلما دعت الحاجه كانت معظم
هذه المواجهات دفاعا مشروعا عن النفس هجمت
القوات الايرانيه اولا وحداتنا العسكريه
خلال معظم هذه المواجهات في حالات اخرى
كانت القوات الايرانيه تدرب مجموعات
ارهابيه لالحاق الاذى بنا والاكراد في مثل
هذه الحالات هجمت وحدات عسكريه لدينا على
القوات الايرانيه الان نحن نوحد الجهود
لتشجيع الاجراءات المدنيه الجماعيه نحن
نبذل جهودا لدعم الاحتجاج المدنيه وانهاء
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه بهذه الطريقه بمساعده
شعوب ايرانيه اخرى نحاول اسقاط الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه
لكي ايران
جمهوريه
هل لديكم اي دور في دعم هذه المظاهرات
الحاليه فئران
حزب كوسبايتين في الواقع نظرا لاننا حزب
مع جيش فنحن متشابكون مع شعبنا في كردستان
نحن لسنا منقسمون عن شعبنا وهم غير منفصل
عن نحن مع شعبنا اثناء الاحتجاجات في
الشوارع وفرنا الحمايه لشعبنا في اي وقت
واجهنا فيه تهديدات من قوات النظام نحن لا
نخفي حقيقه اننا ندعم شعبنا لطرد القوات
الايرانيه من كردستان كيف تدعمون
المظاهرات والمتظاهرين
من خلال طرق متعدده طالبنا شعبنا بالثوره
على نظام طهران نظرا لان لدينا علاقه
روحيه ومعنويه مع شعبنا فقد استجاب الناس
لدعواتنا في اوقات اخرى قمنا بدعوه شعبنا
الى شن اضرابات بالاضافه الى ذلك طلبنا من
انصارنا الوقوف الى جانب الشعب والثوره ضد
وحشيه القوات الايرانيه جرح عدد من ابناء
شعبنا واستشهد العديد قدر المستطاع ساعدنا
في تامين العلاج الطبي للمصابين ساعد
اعضائنا في كردستان الشرقيه في نقل الجرحى
كما ساعد اعضائنا عائلات الشهداء وقدموا
الدعم الروحي والمعنوي هذه هي الطرق التي
تمردنا بها مع شعبنا في كردستان الشرقيه
ضد النظام
فقط السلطات الايرانيه تتحدث عن دعم اكبر
من الشق المعنوي فقط تقول انكم تسلحون
وترسلون عناصر الى الداخل الايرانيه لدعم
المظاهرات
يمكنني ان اخبركم المزيد عن انشطتنا في
شرق كردستان لقد وصلنا اصوات شعبنا الى
المجتمع الدولي شاركنا المجتمع الدولي
بمقاطع فيديو عن عمليات القتل التي
ارتكبها النظام خلال الاحتجاجات المدنيه
لقد تواصلنا مع وسائل الاعلام الدوليه
والدول هذا ما فعلناه اذا ارسلنا اسلحه او
تدخلنا عسكريا في كردستان الشرقيه لما
اخفينا ذلك كنا نتحدث بصراحه عن ذلك لكن
هذه الادعاءات والاتهامات خاطئه تماما
حكام طهران يكذبون كالعاده لديهم اهداف
معينه يسعون اليها من خلال اثاره مثل هذه
المزاعم ضدنا وضد شعبنا اهدافهم واضحه
يريدون تبرير قتل الابرياء يريدون ايضا
تبرير هجماتهم بالصواريخ والطائرات
المسيره على قواتنا في اقليم كردستان هذا
هو السبب في انهم يكذبون
بعضين
نعتقد ان حريه هذه الشعوب هي طريقهم نحو
الازدهار جربنا وسائل اخرى وتعلمنا انه لا
يمكننا العيش بحريه وسلام ورخاء داخل
الدوله الايرانيه ذلك لان الانظمه الحاكمه
وثقافتها غير متوافقه مع معالجه الحريه
والديمقراطيه لكل من الشعوب المذكوره
تجاربهم المرير مع الانظمه الحاكمه في
ايران كانت الانظمه في طهران تسفق دماء
الاكراد والعرب والبلوش والاثريين مما
اسفر عن مقتل قادتهم امر مهم اخر هو ان
سقوط النظام الايراني سيؤدي ايضا الى
ازدهار الامه الفارسيه لان النظام
الايراني لم يتم اختياره بشكل طبيعي مع
سقوطه سيتم ايضا تحرير الفرس من
الديكتاتوريه والشموليه حلاوه على ذلك
سيتم انقاذ منطقه الشرق الاوسط من الارهاب
الذي نشره النظام الايراني وقبل الاضرار
باي دوله اخرى في المنطقه يضر هذا الارهاب
بالشعوب الايرانيه استعمر النظام الايراني
ايران وشعوبها ولانهاء حكمه الاستعماري
وايقاف ارهابه في المنطقه افضل طريقه هي
تدمير هذا النظام المختلق الذي لا يستطيع
توحيد الشعوب
الا تعتقدون بان مطلب الانفصال سيفقدكم
بحلفاء ومؤيدين ومتعاطفين حتى من اوساط
المعارضين للنظام في ايران
يجب ان اقول ان الدوله الايرانيه غير
متوافقه مع الديمقراطيه لقد جربنا ذلك
لمده 100 عام ساعطيكم مثالا جديدا ايضا
جماعات المعارضه الفارسيه التي فشلت في
جميع عشره الاف شخص داخل ايران ليست نشطه
داخل البلاد تتمركز هذه الجماعات في لندن
واشنطن وحتى من الان يهاجمون الاكراد
والشعوب غير الفارسيه نحن لا نشهد اي جو
ديمقراطي في ايران من ناحيه اخرى لا
يمكنني انا والاحزاب الاخرى تحديدا ما
يطلبه شعبنا ما نناضل من اجله هو ما تؤمن
به احزابنا يوجد حل لهذا الموقف حل قانوني
المراجعه العوده الى اصوات الناس دعونا
نطلب من شعبنا رؤيه ما يريدونه حقا
استفتاء في كردستان استفتاء حر يمكن لشعب
كردستان التصويت واعلانه مطالبهم اي حزب
يعتقد ان شعب كردستان لا يريد الاستقلال
يجب ان يحاولوا اجراء استفتاء يجب اجراء
استفتاء تحت اشراف الامم المتحده والاتحاد
الاوروبي ومراقبه وسائل الاعلام
دعونا نرى ما الذي سيصوت له شعب كردستان
سيحترم حزب الحريه الكردستاني النتائج ايا
كانت الاستفتاء الذي يسمح للناس ان يقرروا
ما يريدون هو الطريق الوحيده لحل هذه
المساله دعونا نسمع من شعب كردستان انفسهم
لمثل هذا الاستفتاء ندعو شعبنا بالفعل الى
التصويت لصالح الاستقلال يجب الا ننسى
ايضا ان لدينا تجربه استقلال في كردستان
الشرقيه في عام
1946 كان لدينا دوله كرديه مستقله في شرق
كردستان كان اسم تلك الدوله جمهوريه
كردستان وفي حال تغير النظام الايراني هل
ستستمرون في رفع مطلب الانفصال
خالد شيزور
ناسكو اود مناقشه مساله دقيقه لم يتم
تسليط الضوء عليها كثيرا نحن الاكراد في
ايران لدينا قضيتان رئيسيتان احدها هو
المشكله الاساسيه مع ايران كدوله المشكله
الاخرى هي مشاكلنا مع التشكيلات السياسيه
التي حكمت ايران مشكله اساسيه مع دوله
ايران بغض النظر عن الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
او النظام الملكي لم تحل مشاكلنا العالقه
مع ايران مشكلتنا مع الدوله وليست تكوين
السياسي فقط منذ قيام الدوله الايرانيه لم
نكن جزءا من التشكيل السياسي في الواقع تم
انشاء الدوله الايرانيه من خلال مذابح
الاكراد تاسست من خلال نشر جيشهم في
كردستان لذلك نحن نرفض رفضا قاطعا دوله
ايران وبالمثل فان التشكيلات السياسيه في
ايران تصرفت بهذه الطريقه ايضا هناك بعض
الدول التي لديها تشكيل سياسي ديمقراطي
ولكن هناك مشاكل هويه لم يتم حلها مثل
الباسك في اسبانيا التشكيل السياسي
الديمقراطي لكن الحكومه لم تقبل نتائج
الاستفتاء لذلك لا توجد ضمانات بانه اولئك
الذين سياتون بعد الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
سيتصرفون بشكل مختلف
مختلفا عن الملك رضا بهلوي الملك محمد رضا
بهلوي الخميني وخامني لذلك من خلال انهاء
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه نود انهاء الظروف
الحاليه التي تفرض علينا في كردستان هذا
يعني ان لدينا الحق في تقرير مستقبلنا هذا
يعني ايضا اننا لا نريد ان يحكم الفرس في
كردستان نريد ان نعيش الحريه وان تكون
لدينا تشكيلات سياسيه مستقله مثل باقي
الشعوب النظام الايراني يقول الان ان
المظاهرات الاخيره التي كانت انطلقت في
سبتمبر انتهت فشلت لم تحقق شيئا هل
تعتقدون فعلا بانها فشلت نخيل
لا الاحتجاجات لم تنتهي بعد الاسباب وراء
هذه الاحتجاجات في الحقيقه كانت ثوره وليس
احتجاجات لان الاسباب التي ادت الى الثوره
لا تزال قائمه لذلك ستستمر الثوره ومع ذلك
قد تتغير النماذج والطرق يعتمد ايضا على
فصل السنه من الاسهل على الناس التواجد في
الشوارع في الصيف والخريف الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه تكذب كالعاده ستستمر الثوره
بالتاكيد حتى تحقيق الاهداف النهائيه
في الشوارع الى شكل اخر الثوره مستمره
الان في شكل تصامات اضرابات جنازات
شهيدتان
هل نستطيع القول لان المظاهرات على الاقل
تراجعت وان لم تفشل
بالطبع
هذا صحيح
الثوره لم تنتهي بعد ولقد غيرت الاساليب
يتعلق بالموسم والى حد اكبر يتعلق الامر
بحجم العنف الذي استخدمته الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه لكن الاسباب الاساسيه لا تزال
دون حل لذلك سنرى بالطبع شعبنا في الشوارع
بقوه اكبر يجب ان ينتهي هذا النظام
ما نحن نتابع هذه المظاهرات في داخل
الايراني هناك ردود فعل غربيه
هناك مسعى لفرض عقوبات على كيانات وقيادات
ايرانيه هناك مسعى كذلك لتصنيف كيانات
كالحرس الدوليه الايراني منظمه ارهابيه ما
تقييمك للمواقف الاوروبيه هل هي جاده في
هذا تصنيف ام تعتقد بانها متردده
في الواقع سقطت الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
بالفعل في اذهان الناس ما ابقى الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه هو العلاقات مع اوروبا والموقف
الضعيف للولايات المتحده ومع ذلك هذا
يتغير لقد غيرت الولايات المتحده موقفها
ولا تريد الدخول في مفاوضات مع ايران ايضا
غير الاوروبيون مواقفهم لان ايران لم تعد
تمتلك ربحا اقتصاديا لاوروبيين وقد ثار
الشعب على النظام نرحب بتصنيف الحرس
الفوري الايراني كمنظمه ارهابيه لقد تاخرت
كثيرا لكن هذا افضل من عدمه في الوقت نفسه
نشعر ببعض الشك بين الدول الاوروبيه نامل
ان يكونوا واثقين من قرارهم نامل ان يقوم
الاتحاد الاوروبي والدول الاوروبيه بتصنيف
الحرس الثوري الايراني كمنظمه ارهابيه
وعمليا ما الذي يعنيه تصنيف كيانات كالحرس
منظمه ارهابيه كيف سينعكس هذا الامر عليكم
ليس اليد الوحيد لايران القيام باغراض
ارهابيه بشكل عام الدوله الايرانيه هي
دوله ارهابيه نشهد ارهاب دوله في ايران
انه ليس ارهابا جماعيا فقط في النظام
الايراني هناك مؤسسات اخرى تستخدم لاغراض
ارهابيه وزاره الاستخبارات الجيش الايراني
هذه هي اذرع الارهاب الرئيسيه للدوله ماذا
تعني هذه الخطوات بالنسبه لنا سيثبت ان ضد
النظام والحرس الثوري الايراني لمده 44
عاما كانت ضد الارهاب ان قضيتنا شرعيه
وسوف تطفي مزيدا من الشرعيه على نضالنا ضد
النظام هذا انجاز للشعب الكردي ولحزب
الحريه الكردستاني والجيش الوطني
الكردستاني
الان بعد ان تحرك الاتحاد الاوروبي نحو
هذا القرار وقد تتخذ المملكه المتحده
قرارا مشابها الملح الوقت لياتوا ويدعمون
بالافعال تم ادراج الحرس الثوري الايراني
على قائمه الارهاب اليس مثل داعش حان
الوقت لان يدعمنا الغرب بالسلاح وفي
مجالات اخرى حتى نتمكن من الدفاع عن شعبنا
ضد الحرس الثوري الايراني والتشكيلات
الايرانيه الاخرى هل هذا يعني انكم لا
تدعمون الان من اوروبا او الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
حتى استهز دوله لا لا يوجد شيء حتى هذه
اللحظه لم يكن هناك اي من اي دوله لقواتنا
هذا نقص من جانبهم كل الدول التي تريد
القضاء على الارهاب في الشرق الاوسط يجب
ان تعلم ان ايران هي راس الافعى ايران هي
محرك الارهاب في الشرق الاوسط وايقاف هذه
الاله العملاقه من الانصاف ان اوروبا
والولايات المتحده والدول الاقليميه
والعربيه التي تشكل ايران تهديدا لها ايضا
يجب ان تدعمنا ولكنكم دربتم مسلحتم من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في برنامج خاص
بمكافحه تنظيم داعش الم تستخدموا هذا
السلاح او هذا التدريب في مواجهه النظام
الايراني
في دولتك بامريكا اثناء القتال ضد داعش لم
تزودنا اي دوله بالاسلحه بما في ذلك
الولايات المتحده شاركت قواتنا في بعض
الدورات التدريبيه ومع ذلك لم يكن التدريب
خاصا بقواتنا حيث اشتمل على قوات اخرى
لقتال داعش لذا حتى هذه اللحظه لم يتم
تدريب قوات بشكل خاص ولم نتكلم اسلحه
لكننا نريد ان يتم تدريب قواتنا وتزويدها
ايضا بالاسلحه لاننا جيش ضد الارهاب
وارهاب الدوله الايرانيه ونحن ضد كل
الجماعات الارهابيه الموجوده في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط تستحق القوات التابعه لنا ان
يتم تدريبها ومنحها اسلحه من قبل الدول
حتى الان لم يتم القيام بذلك بعد
وهذا لا يجعلكم فصيلا مدعوما من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لا لا يدعمنا احد
تختلفون كاحزاب كرديه ايرانيه معارضه في
المسعى في الاهداف بين الانفصال والاداره
الذاتيه او تغيير النظام هل هناك اي تنسيق
بينكم
استراتيجيه
لدى الاحزاب استراتيجيات مختلفه لكن هذا
ليس حاجزا امام الحوار والتنسيق نقوم
بالتنسيق والتعاون مع الاطراف الاخرى الى
حد ما نحاول ايضا توسيع هذا التنسيق
التعاون نحن نوحد جهودنا في الاحزاب
الكرديه لتاسيس جبهه كرديه موحده ولكن نحن
معكم اليوم دراجتين ميديا عربيه كان
ما ذكرته لا يشمل الاعلام العربي وسائل
الاعلام العربي اقل قربا من الاحداث
الجاريه في ايران والاحداث المتعلقه
بالشعب الكردي لكن تقاريرهم تعكس الحقائق
مقارنه بالوسائط المملوكه للفرس سؤال
الاخير يقال انكم لا تسعون فقط
للانفصال عن ايران وانما تسعون لانشاء
وتاسيس دوله كرديه تضم كل المناطق الاكراد
في ايران في تركيا في سوريا في العراق هل
هذا دقيق اما
دوق وناغه ودبابه يوجد هنا موضوعان
ومرحلتان مرتبطان ببعضهم البعض المرحله
الحاليه وواجبنا كحزب الحريه الكردستاني
هو النضال من اجل استقلال كردستان الشرقيه
في غضون ذلك نحن ندعم الشعب الكردي في
المنطقه الذي يناضل من على حريته هذه امه
يبلغ عدد سكانها 50 مليون نسمه ولهم الحق
في ان يكونوا مستقلين هذا ايضا عامل للامن
والاستقرار في المنطقه
تعيش
هذا يعني ان الارض التي نحن عليها الان
كردستان العراق هي جزء من الدوله التي
تحلمون بانشائها هذه الارض هي جزء من
كردستان التي نحلم بالوصول اليها حسين
يزدادنا زعيم حزب تحرير كردستان وقائد
الجناح العسكري للحزب شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا
لكم ايضا
شكرا على شجاعتكم في القدوم الى هذا
المكان